just say that's nice that looks like a
bearish ended for the show like it's got
some mess on it but it's organized mess
mark doesn't give I don't know seriously
that's that's just gonna that's just
that's timing right there next comic
coming up here is great he's hilarious
and he's a friend of mine and he's
actually one of the nicest guys I've
ever met in comedy which I can't say
that about 99% of the comics I know so
he's extra special
please meet up for mark Normand
everybody mark all right all right well
thank you Kemal not racist yeah whoo all
right sorry so late coming here I don't
know if you know we got a fleshlight in
the bag I have been busy
all right yeah flew here flew here from
New York boy I hate flying that's the
worst part about this gig I hate flying
I like a train give me an Amtrak any day
I love a train tres have such low self
esteem you know no bag check no security
it's almost like they want a terrorist
huh I love it I hate flying flying is so
high-maintenance flying is like a
high-maintenance chick like you want to
get inside me got here an hour early
take your shoes off and do a body scan
you're like Jesus Christ trains like a
fat chick like get a beer get it in no
security whatsoever you can walk on a
train with three suitcase full of
cocaine like hey you see something say
something
choo-choo ah this is how sad and lonely
trains are trays don't ask to see your
boarding pass until the train has left
the station
yeah you've already started moving and
then they ask how much could they really
care tickets please I don't have one I
gotta buy one now I don't have any money
we'll figure it out
enjoy Dallas
yeah I got here on the afternoon
everybody's already boozed up this is a
real boozy fest yeah yeah I like to
drink I gotta cut back I was so hungover
today and that amazing we still can't
prevent a hangover we've all this
technology I've tried the water I've
tried the pills up and works we can
prevent children we can't run a hangover
at least some people want kids
I've never woken up like whoo I am
really hungover but you know what I
think I want to keep it oh yeah runs in
the family my uncle's a mess yeah my
uncle's actually a 30 years sober can't
believe that 30 years sober
yeah the other night I was like ah man I
got so drunk I lost my phone my uncle's
like oh yeah
I did that once I was like wow you know
drunk you have to be to lose your phone
thirty years ago
holy hell are you telling me you got a
hammer and lost the landline
got some fun gay guys out there any any
gays in here alright yes thanks for
coming out literally I love the gays gay
guys are the best I don't get the whole
homophobia thing any homophobes here
I think homophobia can actually be kind
of dangerous you know friend of mine
he's kind of a tough guy he went
skydiving recently he's like yeah I'm
not strapping some guy on my back that's
super gay that's just a weird thing to
put your energy into you know I saw a
guy in Central Park once he was ranting
about gays adopting kids what a weird
thing to be angry about I liked seeing a
gay couple the kid you see a gay couple
the kid no there's no way that kid was
an accident right no gay couple could
never get that up like holy
what happened last night
good lord oh my god we robbed an
orphanage holy moley oh my god
yeah give gay couples kids you know
shouldn't have kids poor people why is
that allowed it's a terrible idea
my parents are poor I'm a comedian
red flags I don't know sometimes I wish
I was gay you know I got fired for my
last job for sexual harassment I told a
woman she had nice cleavage they fired
me which pissed me off because my gay
friends at work we're gonna weigh with
murder they begged hey Shelly how are
you honk-honk it's like what why is that
okay like well not attracted to women I
was like so what I'm not attracted to
kids I can't go to a playground hey
Timmy oh yeah I don't get stuff like
that you know I'm trying to learn but
like like you're a woman wouldn't you
rather be complimented by a group that's
into you I don't care for lesbian
complements me nothing against lesbians
but I didn't help my ego you know yeah
the lesbians like hey Mark like a
haircut I'm like I know you have the
same one
I don't know racism homophobia how do
you hate a whole group that's what I
don't get how do you eat a whole group
of people Jews blacks gays how do you in
a whole group
I hate specifics about people you know
like like people who drink rock star and
believe in ghosts and say it is what it
is I don't get it but you know uh racism
it's alive and well man I was just down
in Knoxville Tennessee you guys ever
been there yeah what a
holy hell they are 30 years behind over
there you go to a town so small there's
still racist towards certain white
people you know they're like hey watch
out over there that's what the dirty
Irish live I was like Jesus Christ
Wow you guys haven't made it to black
people yet oh my god you're far behind
pick it up come on I live in New York
City we're past Arabs let's go and again
these are all jokes take it easy I I'm
not racist I look at racism the same way
I look at Nickelback yeah you know it's
it's fun to joke about but uh you never
want to see it live yeah I grew up in
Louisiana I grew up in Louisiana yeah
yeah I grew up with this guy hates
minorities every type of minority hates
them all which is weird to me because he
just had a baby I find that strange
because when you think about it babies
and minorities of all the same negative
stereotypes if you hate minorities you
should eat babies too yeah think about
it babies are loud movie theaters I
can't swim they all look alike right
they're lazy they don't work you know
they can't drive terrible tippers yeah
yeah they come to this country not
knowing the language
but he loves a baby I don't get it but
you know you can't be racist in public
these days that's for sure yeah it's
very risky lose your job you'd
ostracized from society that's why if
anyone's ever raised in public around
you now you know they trust you yeah
it's kind of this weird bittersweet
moment you know you're on a smoke break
with some guys like man I can't stand
Mexicans you like holy you're full
of hate but I didn't know we were so
close oh my god Wow we should move in
together I mean who's gonna clean the
place we'll figure it out oh yeah come
on don't clam up on me now sup bye hi
all jokes jokes got a joke about this
stuff yeah I don't know hating a whole
group I saw a thing any any Jews here
all right
too many ah I saw a thing on the news of
the day about neo-nazis heard of these
guys neo-nazi what a crazy concept
neo-nazi do you really need the NiO yeah
you got Nazi in there I think you're
cool okay is that named Chaney anyone's
behind neo-nazi I'm listening ah come on
you're a hate group do you really need a
new hip name other hate groups don't do
that hey we're not the KKK anymore we're
K cubed yeah things have changed around
here baby new sheets higher thread count
yeah oh yeah I uh I used to date a
Jewish gal I just found out she wants to
get breast implants that blew my mind
I used to term breast implants cuz I
don't like the term fake breasts I like
the turn it doesn't make sense to me
because the breasts are real is just the
inside that's fake yeah actual
breasts are still real it's kind of like
the Bible the book is real just the
inside it's fake book is real it's
leather yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I gotta figure
something out I'm getting older man I'm
getting older uh about a year ago I got
paranoid about losing my hair started
taking propecia could not get an
erection yeah you remember yeah this
girl that was dating at the time was
like hey you gotta get off those pills
I'd rather you have a boner than hair
which is nice to hear but I only makes
sense when you're dating somebody at
work in the beginning like if I was a
bald guy that here on a bar like hey
gonna buy you a drink
she's like I'm good I'm I got I have a
boner I know you prefer that to here huh
but hey maybe I mean a nice scale at
this festival you know I could pretend
to have tattoos yeah yeah haha newly
single guy back on the scene went on a
date with a girl recently went pretty
well back to her place I take out a
condom she goes whoa whoa whoa where'd
you get that thing I was like well they
were free at the bar she was like oh
that's gross I was like well that's
where I got you
dates are tough now too cos we have no
patience we want everything so quick we
want everything quick we have no
patience we want tinder fast-food
delivery high-speed Internet everything
is so quick the only we don't want quick
as sex when is that gonna catch up I was
with a girl the other night I finished
kind of early she's like hey what's
going on here I was like wow these are
the times we're living in
come on I don't the patients your vagina
to be buffering let's go they're an
analogue girl in the digital world
sister pick it up yeah uh-huh I'll deal
with a girl recently she said she likes
a strong silent type
wow that's mildly offensive huh match of
a guy said that what do you look for in
a woman
silence yeah yeah like a woman is tough
and shut the up that's what I'm
into yes yeah you gals can see a lot of
stuff like my last girlfriend dumped me
said I wasn't manly enough for her not a
manly guy that one hurt I know we're
allowed to say stuff like that like I'm
all about equality but how good woman
can say something like yeah like guy was
good with his hands he can fix it up
around the house girl but if a guy says
hey I like what we can cook people go
whoa whoa it's not the 50s
well how come her job for me is okay but
my job person okay also who doesn't like
somebody can fix you it around the house
I'd love to come on my girl ones like
hey I bills a dick right awesome
I'll do laundry yeah
see I think women are you guys are so
smart cuz you guys made your gender
roles offensive yeah that was very
clever
well played ladies well played guys how
great would that be if we could offend a
girlfriend wait you before am I heard
glass shattering somebody breaking in
you're like well it's not the 50s go
check it out all right
thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart
Fargo and everybody area
[Applause]